do you know someone who's a big Fallout
fan and are you having trouble thinking
of a gift idea for them because they've
been spending way too much time
wandering the wastelands of Fallout 4
call your intrepid vault dwellers in
from the cold this holiday season with
these vault Tec approved fallout themed
gift ideas if your prospective gift
recipient has already made themselves at
home and fallout 4 why not bring a
little bit of fallout into their home
with this life-size replica pip-boy
cinches tight around your arm and houses
a variety of Apple or Samsung devices it
may only be available on eBay
until Bethesda announces another
production run but fortunately the app
that makes your smartphone look like a
pip-boy is free it's all the fun of
being a vault dweller and none of the
giant irradiated cockroaches trying to
kill you when you see a hulking green
man with giant muscles in fallout 4 or a
Marvel movie or a real life it's
generally a good idea to keep your
distance there are some diamonds in the
rough however including this super
mutant figure from Funko pop he's got a
stern gaze and an alarmingly big hammer
but inside he's all heart aren't you big
guy aren't you're not I'm gonna put him
down discovering the many mysteries of
post-apocalyptic Boston is one of the
great joys of fallout 4 but hurts to be
just a little bit more prepared for the
stuff you might encounter out there for
the ultimate in virtual world
preparedness consult the ultimate vault
dweller survival guide a detailed tome
that is chock-full of information on
people places perks and plenty of other
useful things that don't even begin with
the letter P and if all this talk of
virtual survival has you thinking about
the real-world survival of those on your
gift lists this two-person survival kit
from ready America is packed with a
bunch of basics that will be a boon to
them in case of any short-term emergency
with water food first-aid blankets and
more it's not gonna take care of
anything fallout throws at you but it
will help in a short-term emergency and
give you some peace of mind to boot with
all these gift ideas you're sure to
survive the holiday events in style and
be a part of rebuilding the world in
their wake for a better tomorrow
you